you are about to enjoy a free preview
from the disney n pixar film light year
now available
mission log supplement after borrowing a
ship from star command i've achieved
hyper speed and i'm ready to finally
leave this planet once and for all
buzz lightyear to star command come in
star command
star command come in
why don't they answer
hey
the what
the robots
wait what's it doing
my [ __ ] quiet where'd it go
up there
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
where's the pilot
what is that what is going on
[Music]
come on
they must have seen your ship land too
who the robots why are there robots
where did the robots come from where did
you come from i came from here here
wait
bus
alicia
oh no that's my grandmother i'm izzy
izzy
but but you were just a little
sucks how long were we gone
22 years 19 weeks and four days whoa
wait
come on
in here
i thought i heard one a robot yeah
impressive well i am a hawthorn you sure
are you know your grandma and i can
practically finish each other's
sentences if you're anything like her
you and i are gonna make some robots cry
okay
so
get me up to speed on this right zerg
ship showed up about a week ago what's a
zerg oh well that's the only thing the
robots say so that's what we call the
big ship the zerg ship arrived the robot
surrounded the base and then well
citizens of the county prime robot
aliens have attacked everyone inside the
perimeter look out we are activating the
laser shield immediately
and that's the last we heard
all those people
they were counting on me
and now they're trapped
we've tried to reach them but there's no
communication in or out socks
she's correct
did you just check me against your cat
well he's not your standard issue feline
actually socks was a gift from your
grandmother hello izzy hello socks
hey what's that noise come on don't
break my cat he's purring he likes it
sucks do you like that i do
huh
well i hope you're ready for action
because all we needed was a pilot for
what i have a plan and i have a team
come on
so
all right team
fall
in found a pilot operation surprise
party is a go
i like this an elite squad best of the
best you know her grandmother was the
greatest space ranger in the history of
the corps it'll be an honor to work with
you come on gather round team
let's review our objectives kill the
robots and don't die
don't die it's just something you want
to do every day it's still an objective
if i may we have one objective we need
to put this crystal in the turnip and
get out of here so to do that we have to
get onto the base to do that we have to
kill all the robots to do that we have
to destroy the zerg ship and to do any
of that we have to not die
um derek allow me to explain operation
surprise party it is a variation on
operation thunder spear didn't you get a
medal for that one two actually but uh
wait how do you know about operation
thundersphere i've read all my grandma's
space ranger books from cover to cover
twice
excuse me robot kitty cat oh sorry
sensors have indicated that dessert ship
powers the robots on the ground so we
fly up there we blow up the ship and
surprise robots you're toast then we put
your crystal in the turnip and finish
the mission
it's a good plan
to
infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that it was uh sorry it's a
thing your grandma and i used to do yeah
i we never she didn't mean to anyway
forget it moving on
let's load these munitions into the
armadillo and steal ourselves for combat
operation surprise party is on
buzz uh did you hear that i hear
something
you think it's a robot no we've never
seen a robot this far from the base i
don't hear anything
now i do
[Music]
did
the junior patrol has your back the
junior what
[Music]
sorry i'm not trained with this weapon
let me reload it not trade wait what do
you mean you're not trained
[Music]
dude you there grab it grab it have what
oh i'm not allowed to handle weapons be
a violation of my parole parole bus izzy
now
no
okay new plan new plan what was the old
plan i need that anyone saying the
harpoons they came pre-loaded with a
harpoon i can't i don't i found them so
i found the harpoons i'm going to reload
it now check this out
did i get it to the left
what
did i get it
you got it yes
[Music]
boom ugh
see what happens next order the entire
movie disney and pixar's light gear now
available radio pg